joey cora and tariq brock third and
first base coaches respectively at
telling jim tridinich in st louis that
they were placing their helmets
in their respective coaching boxes and
pausing to reflect as a symbolic gesture
to bring further attention to the
continued social injustice within our
society a look at kk the lefty starter
for st louis a quick worker
in the 1-1
up the middle at a base hit and that's
how we start this double letter no
injuries no cuts no bruises
that's hit and caught down at third what
a catch
down at third by miller in foul
territory hung up just enough to make
that backhand aground but thank you for
your concern yeah absolutely concerned
and absolutely happy that miller makes
his play probably going to be a foul
ball and it would have been but better
than that it's an out look at that snow
cone and the 2-2
swing and a miss he struck him out five
games for chad one and one at 284
earned run average just strikeout
printing
he's gonna get his first put out
in the big leagues and as routine as it
could be
cool quickly on it
he is uh
outstanding athlete
half swinging and will craig has just
tied
a major league
record how about that in his first game
and there's a fly ball lifted out to
deep left field going back o'neil near
the wall and he is got it up against the
wall
tyler o'neil with the catch crashing up
against the left field wall
and the wall lost
believe me
it sure did it sure did and the winner
is kim the pitcher and the loser is
stallings who thinks he got it i thought
it got in on him a little bit i'm
surprised it carried this far but
there's tyler making the play up against
the wall he's trying to feel for the
wall has a general idea
and a swing and a miss in the second
strikeout
[Applause]
now molina
pops this pitch up and osuna giving
chase nicely done jose osun he's gonna
fire towards second base and there's
gonna be a double play make it up nicely
done yeah jose osuna look at fredberg
sitting
down big mac landing again they're
trying to get his seat he's talking to
all the fans out there trying to get the
rhythmic chant going out there clapping
his hands
and there's a fly ball
out to deep left o'neal back and makes
the catch on the run crashes up against
the wall
the runner doesn't tag
tucker staying put at second base what a
play there by tyler o'neill
and tucker's still at second base and
the wall takes a beating again what a
play here and he went a long way to get
this
again that ball carrying to left field
and there's tyler on the move and up
against the wall
runners had first and second
he got um elevated that fastball and a
strikeout for kim his third of the
afternoon jacob stallings at the plate
hanging curve that's sent out into left
base hit tucker around third he's going
to score
two out rbi single for jacob stallings
and the pirates lead one nothing through
the first three innings
up and in fastball good pitch popped up
down the left field line and gonzalez
tracks it down in fairground to make a
really great grab one out
last time cardinals won a game after
trailing by three or more runs with two
outs in the ninth inning or later
and that is hit
out to deep right and the catch is made
by dexter fowler nice play dex nice play
here by dex what a play
we've seen some really good outfield
play in this game and dexter can add
that one to the list
the cardinals bad in the fifth inning
down one nothing
and yadi hits one out to deep left at
the wall
gone
yada yamolina his first of 2020
and he's tied it
it's tied 1-1
on yachty's first of the year
so first and second nobody out and josh
bell drew a walk his last time around
here she comes
little chopper could be two wong a flip
and they get to
wang edmund carpenter double play four
six three actually the bottom of the
ninth
tapper
with tough play osuna and got him the
big stretch from craig
and one big out
big play osuna with the body control
and will craig how about that reflexes
[Applause]
and just pop up the shallow center
tucker giving chase and he makes a fine
grab
paul tucker you could see the
concentration as he kept his eyes on
that ball that was dropping quickly and
he goes down to the ground and we are
going extra innings still at second the
pinch runner dyson
one out tucker
reaches out and drops it into center
field and the pirates will take the lead
dyson scores
on the coal tucker single the pirates
lead it 2-1
so runners at the corners now brings in
brian reynolds and swinging the ball
lined it over short and into center for
a base hit
tucker's going to score
and bell will scoot into second base two
out rbi single for brian reynolds
pirates are up three to one
[Applause]
bounce off the glove of the third
baseman miller into left bell will score
pirates lead four to one
and the tying run will come to the plate
just like that and here we go again
left reynolds giving chase
and makes the catch and that looked like
it would have been a fair ball
fowler scores to make it 4-2
that is a huge play here you go paul
goldsmith comes up representing
the winning run
goldsmith off of the pitcher into
shallow right
one run in
and the cardinals are certainly making
this interesting yet again
yep
so that's what it comes down to the
strikeout the second out max schrock is
gonna pinch hit for tyler o'neill he did
he got the save and he can raise the
jolly roger